the first five or eight years of making
movies most people would be like what
are you trying to do
and you'd almost feel weird to say i'm a
filmmaker
i think you have a theory that i find
interesting you must navigate from where
you are not from where you wish to be
yeah that's right how does that guide
your life and how does that guide
filmmaking
let's see i was
23 years old when my dad told me you
have to navigate from where you are not
from where you wish to be
and he
was studying buddhism at the time
and what that really is translating to
you is the idea that you will feel like
you're someplace else
but your feet are firmly placed in a
different position
so a lot of times and at the time for me
specifically
for instance in terms of my filmmaking i
was making movies and maybe was viewing
these movies on a higher scale than they
needed to be viewed and not planting my
feet into the position of it's amazing
i'm getting these films finished
but now i need to navigate into what is
telling a story you know because i think
in the beginning of making a movie
you
find yourself in the position of how do
you write a script
and then you write the script and you're
like okay well now how do i translate
that to in front of the camera and you
start to answer those questions
and i believe at some point it suddenly
becomes okay now i know how to make a
movie period i know all the different
departments so how do you make a good
movie you know how do you make something
compelling how do you make somebody feel
emotion
and then how do you surprise
and i feel like where i've landed today
that's i'm really excited about
is now that i've made three features and
36 shorts there's this point when i'm
writing that i'm like okay i know the
actor is going to get this screenplay
from me
so are there three or four scenes i can
change
their script
that they don't know what's going to
actually happen
and that's what i'm doing in these new
movies coming up is as there's certain
scenes i will intentionally not tell
them the way it's going to go
just to see if theoretically they become
it's not all about surprising someone
either it can just be about
freshening up a character choice at a
particular moment but
if we took that moment where your dad
told you that let's suppose that was a
scene in a movie
[Music]
was this about filmmaking that he told
you this
yes it was okay it was it was everything
i'm very tunnel visioned so when when
april 23 came around and my roommate
told me and i devoted my life to making
movies
nothing else mattered
everything was making movies i watched a
billion movies i read a billion
screenplays i read every book i could
get my hands on the first couple of
years i didn't have any technology i had
a vhs player
and a television
and then i had this really old computer
like a desktop blocky computer for my
dad and i just started writing i was a
horrible student
and i just started writing and writing
and writing and my dad was reading this
horrible script that i was writing
and he's like i can't believe you're
doing this much you know you here let me
get you a camera and he got me a little
camera and then i started doing these
little films where it's just me playing
every role
and cutting them together in the camera
and then
that translated to getting the canon xl2
and it started going that path
and then my dad you know i would just
get into these giant fantasy worlds to
bring it back to
the buddhist statement of you have to
navigate from where you are not from
where you wish to be
he would just always be teaching me that
and telling me you know i'd talk about
wanting to make these larger pieces and
he would tell me you know navigate from
where you are right here and you'll be
able to and then he that that thought
process is also completing every project
i really thoroughly believe
the reason most people don't get to
where they want to go is because they
never complete the thing they started
and that's the most important part of
all of this even if in the middle you're
like this is bad
finish it and then show it and there's
probably going to be some people that
actually like it
and that'll be surprising
would you print these scripts out or
would you just keep them
like on a was it a floppy disk or no no
i did print them out i don't think i
ever kept them backed up but there was
one feature length script that was maybe
84 pages called one day
and it was a
crazy acid trip of a screenplay and my
friend who was a deep deep lover of
novels came over and read it the worst
first person you can imagine to read
something you've ever written
he sat down the worst person is going to
tell you the truth and he sat down he
read the whole thing he sat down said
this is a hunk of crap but let me tell
you
uh
i'm impressed you finished
and it was such a big moment for me i
don't even think he even realized it at
the particular time because just that
little bit of motivation of like well i
did finish that thing
and then kept going
i got to the point where i wanted to do
this so badly i re-taught myself grammar
just so that i could get a brush up on
anything i was messing up in the
screenplay form whether it was the
actual structure or
you know the simple grammar of life
like passive voice versus active i mean
all those kind of things how to use a
comma i mean
you know just particular moments you're
writing five or ten pages in a day and
you always miss these things anyways you
know so just trying to get better
constantly in whatever fashion but at
that time i was in cincinnati where
apartments were and 610 dollars a month
you know and trying to move across the
country was
not existent so
sure yeah but that he he kind of told
you that well he not kind of told you
the truth he did tell you truth but then
he could have just said give up man this
is you know but he didn't and so as many
do the first five or eight years of
making movies most people would be like
what are you trying to do
and you'd almost feel weird to say i'm a
filmmaker like i feel like
during that particular time
you
i mean especially being from ohio
i think the majority of people they want
to do something that they don't push
themselves fully to do and so you do get
a lot of people when you start to have
passion and feel the stuff you feel
people sometimes push against you in
particular ways and
navigating that is just as important as
navigating the compliments
meaning when people give you compliments
they can be just as damaging as
the negativity
really because they're yes people
well not even so much that they're yes
people but
don't get in your head you can always be
better
you know like you might be better than
the 10 people next to you but there's
always going to be
and and forget about all the people
be better for you
you know trying to be your best self is
pretty much the only thing that we're
here to do i think
so if you want to make films then try to
make films better than you can ever make
them you know hence me trying to relearn
grammar and those kind of facets just
be that much better if you could
but
how did you relearn it i mean oh i mean
videos books
yeah just buying things i i used to wake
up at 4 30 in the morning most days and
i would
sit there and work on whatever it was i
was trying to
to better my screenplay writing for
instance it might be like 4 30 in the
morning you know opening an actual class
book to look at grammar and structure
and and then it might be other mornings
it might be like opening specific kinds
of writing and reading them and then
writing your own little essays about
what you think about those because
screenwriting is an open canvas
and the context that wes anderson is
writing scripts that are so novelesque
every detail is in there so you can go
to the degree that you could write a
novel and just put the dialogue in the
middle which is what they kind of do and
their films are amazing
wes anderson and the people he writes
with generally
um
or you can go paul thomas anderson and
it's completely
gutted of a lot of that detail and it's
mainly some basic camera movements and
then the dialogue is all the character
and the depth in it so
what a huge versatile of difference in
the idea of how you're going to write
something
and how do you navigate it because you
know but so but really i think how you
navigate it is find out who you are and
then write
did you ever experience that where you
because you know they say that a lot of
would-be authors do that where they
start writing in the same style same
voice as the author that they read so
much did you find that with any of the
films that you were watching let's
suppose if you watched all of david
fincher's films or whomever that you
like you know what i think i'm copying
this person's style
yeah i intentionally copied david lynch
for the first 10 short films
that's not a bad person i intentionally
tried my hardest to do the weirdest
craziest things i could possibly imagine
but also i think some of that came from
skate videos too
because when i was making those in the
beginning
um and working with that stuff you're
doing so much silly kind of
acting and strange stuff
but
i think in the beginning
you try to copy you try to
imitate or
become something a little bit more close
to what you love
and in turn you inevitably just become
yourself
if you do it long enough
if you do anything long enough you
become yourself in the middle of it
which gus fans saying answered that
exact question with his remake of psycho
because he remade psycho framed by frame
by frame but yet it's still a completely
different movie
and that was his whole experiment going
into it
so they could almost be like a buddhist
saying
if someone's
on a hill
and and
someone says the more you try to become
[Music]
your idol you become you
yeah
honestly because
whenever we've
let's just say with movies right
whenever any of us have fallen in love
with a filmmaker say you have your
stanley kubrick kick right or your david
fincher kick
in the middle of that
you're watching all their work you fall
in love with it but at some point it
dissipates a bit and then you end up as
stephen soderbergh or other or emar
bergman or other filmmakers and then
you're in that little realm that little
bubble now you've already taken stuff
that you've loved from all these other
people andre tarkovsky in any of these
little moments
and inevitably
i think you can't help but be yourself
and sometimes
it just maybe doesn't work maybe it
comes out and it's not necessary i mean
like even when you become yourself you
still have to ask yourself what genre do
you are you most
pulled towards i've done a lot of
different genres and i can't even i
still can't even answer that question
the next film is going to be a horror
film and i've loved scary movies
forever
when i was really tiny like four years
old i watched the shining and i had the
same exact haircut and i was positive it
was me in the movie and that really
messed with me
my dad would fall asleep on the couch
and then i would watch these movies like
well the next night after the shining i
watched apocalypse now because he fell
asleep on the couch in hbo it just
popped up you know in the middle of
midnight they went from twister to
apocalypse now which is kind of a
perfect little double feature
but
um yeah so so
i don't know i think inevitably you
you'll contemplate what it is you want
to do
and then when it comes out it's going to
be i mean filmmaking it's not just you
though it's everyone
right filmmaking is not really a
singular a singular vision keeps it on
track
but if you've brought the right artist
together then you're gonna have
something more beautiful than you ever
imagined and if you don't then you're
not doing it right in my opinion
hopefully
so then it's okay to try to copy because
at first because then eventually you'll
find out
who you are or what genre you are or
amalgamation of things i think in the
very beginning go try to copy everyone
you know why because you have no clue
what lens they used you have no clue
what camera they used and you're gonna
put your camera in a similar position
it's going to look completely different
because you won't have a comprehension
on the difference between a 24
millimeter or an 85 millimeter lens
and that's just inevitably going to make
it feel different even when you're
trying to do something similar because
that's something i noticed when i was
doing all these films with the canon xl2
there was a point
where i learned all the zooming
and i learned moving the camera around
and getting it to a particular position
but then my evolution from that camera
into dslr cameras taught me everything
about lenses when i was very young
or in the very beginning
of making films i went to the camera
store the camera rental house and i took
an action figure and i placed in a
position and they let me try out all
these lenses and i put a piece of paper
in in front of the action figure and it
would tell me if it was a 24 millimeter
lens or an 85 or a 50. and i'll go home
and look at the this material and kind
of try to
understand the grammar i suppose
of it